I'm a Canadian I grew up dependant on
American hegemony my whole vision of the
world was there was a liberal democratic
state that would do the wrong thing
until the end that until the last moment
then kind of do the right thing we're in
a new world the passage of that American
hegemony the emergence of let's be
Franklin and all respect to China great
civilization but this is a single party
this is a single-party state and it's
taking us if this is the power power
that generates door dominates the 21st
century it's an unfamiliar world I do
not think China will be the new Empire
but the idea that the world is led by a
single party state causes anxiety and
and in a post-imperial world a
post-imperial world is wonderful because
we get back to self-determination in my
view we get back to the nation-state as
the driver of politics but were we're
suddenly in a world without the hegemon
that used to have an association of
democratic values and now we're into a
new world I think that produces a great
deal of anxiety and linnea also help if
I could relieve your anxiety a little
bit you earlier pointed out about about
the potential for Chinese dominance of
the world let me say this I will wager
bet today that in 25 years when we
return for the 50th anniversary of the
Nazca Sawa's that that China will not be
dominating the world at that time and
our wager that bet for two reasons one
is because I don't believe China intends
to dominate the world and and number two
is even if they did they would fail at
it because we moved way past beyond the
age of dominance I think it'd still be
difficult for any one power to dominate
the world's the wrong mindset
in my lifetime just in my career
peaceful rise has already happened it's
a fact on the ground
we went from since I started my career
in business we went from a poor agrarian
country to a behemoth that you know that
is China
today but he must in every respect ok
yet no country has been invaded not a
single shot fired no violence and if you
look at human history the rise of every
power from Athenian Empire
to the Roman Empire to the British
Empire to America's manifest destiny to
the rise of modern Germany a modern
Japan Ottoman Empire every single one of
them the rise was accompanied by
tremendous bloodshed colonization Wars
massacres ok and China's rise to date
has been bigger and faster than them all
I shared the same admiration wherefore
the rise of China I really share it I've
been there every year since the eighties
and it's amazing
but you said rightly that the past issue
of empires has been a history of
aggression and supremacy and detriment
so those of us who like to study history
and political science and society now
the rise of China why would it be
different that's why I came back to my
point it's so important that we work
together for a world based on rules also
it's it's in our fundamental interest
for mankind that we have China committed
and now China says that is committed and
the President Xi Jinping has made very
clear commitments about that in United
Nations even in Davos he came to Davos
make that point so the question is the
history shows to us that empires tends
to be assertive sometimes / aggressive
okay now you say to me and I'm sure that
you are sincere that
China will be different but we have to
be sure if you have a sufficient global
order that can prevent us from more
accidents in the future that is my part
you